So today for our experts in
emotion interview series,
we'll be speaking with Dr. Michael
Norton on consumerism and emotion.
So Dr. Norton is an associate professor
of business administration and the
marketing unit and a Marvin Bower
fell at the Harvard business school.
He holds a BA in psychology and English
from Williams college and a phd in
psychology from Princeton University.
Prior to joining the
Harvard Business School,
Dr. Norton was a fellow at the MIT media
lab and Mit Sloan School of management.
He's the coauthor along with Elizabeth
Dunn of the Book Happy Money.
The signs of smarter spending.
His work has been published in a
number of leading academic journals,
including science, the Journal of
personality and social psychology,
Psychological Science,
and the Journal of consumer research.
His work has also been covered in
media outlets including the economist,
the Financial Times, the Wall Street
Journal, and the Washington Post.
Dr. Norton has also appeared
on the national public
radio and written op eds for
the New York Times,
Forbes and the Los Angeles Times.
His research has twice been featured
in the New York Times magazine year in
ideas issue in 2007 for his work
on ambiguity promoting liking.
And in 2009 on the counter if itself his
the Ikea effect when Labor leads to lab
was featured in Harvard Business
Review's breakthrough ideas.
In 2009 in 2010 he won the theoretical
innovation prize from the Society of
personality and social psychology.
In 2011 he won the Sage Young Scholars
Award from the foundation for social and
personality psychology.
And in 2012 he was selected for wired
magazine's smart list as one of the 50
people who will change the world.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview with Dr. Michael Norton on
consumerism and emotion.
Welcome Mike.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
So I'd like to begin by speaking with
you about how you got started studying
emotion. So could you tell us a little
bit about what first got you interested in
emotion?
Sure thing.
So I was working at the time with
my frequent collaborator Dan Ariely,
and Dan is an Israeli Jew.
And I am an Irish Catholic and we made
a bet which was who was more miserable,
uh,
Catholics or Jews.
And the way we decided to test it was
to send some undergrads out to different
places of worship all over Boston and
get pre and post ratings of happiness
before and after religious services.
And we wanted to see the paper was
going to be called any given Sunday.
And the idea was if you had to pick
one religion to go to on any given day,
which one you should you go do to get
happiest. So it really started as a,
and I won't tell you the answer
because it was controversial, but yeah,
I would really started as a bet,
which was if we think about daily
things that we can do in our life,
what are little things that we could do?
So not like how do you get a
better job or increase your salary,
but literally if you've got an extra hour
of time and you wanted to do something
vaguely religious,
what should you go and do?
And then we started to look at also
things like going to the gym and going to
yoga. So what are the best little
activities that you can do to improve your
happiness?
And that really was the interest along
was the little things that you might be
able to do rather than sometimes the
big global things we often think about.
Wow,
that's really interesting.
And how long ago was that
first project that you did?
We did that in probably 2003
or four or something like that.
We've actually published a paper related
to those data, which, which was about,
uh, the fact that religion
makes you really happy,
which a lot of people have shown, but only
if you believe a lot in your religion.
So in fact,
if you look at people who say that they're
Catholic or say that they're a Muslim
and then they don't believe
that much in their religion,
they're actually less happy than people
who don't go to church at all or don't
go to services at all.
So it looks like there's a point at which
it's better to be believe in nothing
than to believe a little bit and
whatever religion you belong to.
Thanks. That's really interesting. Um,
what I'd like to ask you about now,
it's just some questions about
your current research. Um,
so we've all heard the expression,
you've heard it many times,
I'm sure that money can't buy happiness.
Um,
but your recent research suggests
that this is not entirely true.
So in what ways can money
actually make us feel happier?
Yeah, I think that this, uh, um, a lot
of kind of religions have this phrase of,
you know, money can't buy happiness and
a lot of self help gurus have it as well.
And I think the sentiment behind
it is true, which is that, uh,
money isn't the only thing that can buy
you happiness or maybe even more of that.
The key to happiness isn't just money.
So if you think that the only thing you
should do with all your time is get more
money and that's what will make you
really happy, you're probably wrong.
But at the same time,
that doesn't mean that the way that you
use your money can't really impact your
hat happiness a lot.
So when Liz and I started this research,
the idea was basically maybe money can
buy you a little bit more happiness than
it does right now.
And the reason it doesn't right now
is it because we don't spend it well?
And if you think about what
we and I spend our money on,
usually it's things like
stuff for ourselves.
So we buy a bigger TV and a nicer car
and a bigger house and those things are
all great and they're nice to have.
But research shows they don't
really make us that much happier,
are just nice to have.
And we thought, well,
what are things we could get people to
do with their money that are different
than kind of buying stuff for themselves?
And the original idea really was,
well what if we just radically changed
the focus of who you're spending on?
So maybe if you stop spending on
yourself all the time and being selfish,
but spent a little money on
somebody else for a change,
that it might actually
make you a lot happier.
They'd get happier for sure
because they're getting a present.
But it might actually make you happy or
a result of engaging in what we call pro
social spending.
Very interesting. So you know, related to
that, you know, your book with Liz Dunn,
you know, it's talking about
the science of smarter spending.
So I wonder your thoughts on how can we
balance both spending our money wisely
but also trying to be happy as well. How
do we balance those two things at once?
Yeah, it's, it's very hard actually. So I
mean, one of the things that we don't do,
not clearly in general with our
money to save it, uh, so, uh,
savings rates in are very,
very low compared to other countries.
It actually gone up a little
bit since the 2008, 2009.
It looks like they're going back down
again now. Uh, and saving is good.
Not just because it's why
I've just financially and
interest rates and all those
sorts of things.
But because if you save now,
you're basically guaranteeing
yourself some happiness later in life.
So having no money when you're 65 and
is not pleasant because you have to
somehow when you retire.
But again,
those are kind of big longterm decisions
that people make and those are really
important to make.
But would we want it to look at,
are these everyday little behaviors that
you could do right now? So literally,
if you have an extra $5 today,
what should you do with the $5 to
make yourself happiest with that $5?
And it's things like literally rather
than buy yourself a coffee by somebody
else, a coffee. Yeah,
you don't get the caffeine and the
optimum Starbucks thing for yourself,
but giving it away to somebody else and
we have data that that supports this
will make you happier than spending
that little amount of money on yourself.
Sounds like a great book.
I'm looking forward to reading it myself.
Happy money that signs a smarter spending.
Um,
what I thought might be fun to talk
about in our last question is some of the
work that you and I've
been doing together, um,
where are we find that sort of the
greater abundance and variety of emotions
that people experience shows that they're
actually better off both mentally and
physically.
And I think this brings up the question,
is it really better to have more emotions
overall? Uh, even negative emotions?
What are you thinking about this?
Yeah, definitely it comes to mind. So I
think it's, it's pretty counterintuitive.
I think even even for us,
that,
that having more negative
emotions on any given day,
you're feeling ashamed and sad
and fearful and things like that,
that could possibly be
better for you. Hmm. Uh,
but I think if you think about what
the counterfactual universities,
it makes a little bit more sense.
So for example, imagine all day,
every day you felt really happy, every
minute of every day you felt happy, happy,
happy, happy. I think,
and we don't have the data for this
cause no one really feels that way.
I think you'd probably go crazy if you
felt the same exact positive thing all
the time. And if you didn't go crazy
from feeling happy, happy, happy, happy,
you might also just get
used to feeling happy.
And we know that things like adaptation
happen over time, so happy is great,
but we can get weirdly tired of happy
and we can wish that we were something
else other than happy.
And in those cases it might be great to
feel proud instead of happy or another
positive thing,
but it might be the case then it's
sometimes good even to feel scared or sad
instead of happy just to disrupt
the sameness of everyday life.
And I just actually was reading
some interesting research about um,
people who have generalized anxiety
disorder. And one of the issues is that,
that um, the research was suggesting
is that they, if they have,
if they have depression and anxiety,
they don't want to be depressed anymore.
But the idea of doing anything different
provoked so much anxiety that they'd
rather stay depressed then
take the risk of some change.
That might be very anxiety provoking.
And if you think about how that out
with the diversity of your emotions,
it might be better to feel, not just
depressed all the time, but maybe scared,
at least scared is different from feeling
depressed and that might prompt you to
have higher wellbeing.
That's so interesting because if,
you know,
this work is saying that a different
variety of emotions is going to sort of
open our mind to new kinds of experiences
and actually be healthy for healthier
for us.
But at the same time,
some of the people who need that the most
like people suffering from generalized
anxiety disorder having the hardest time
doing it. That's right. Yeah. Interesting.
So you know, this is this work on
emotional, uh, diversity and variety.
Do you think there's any way you can
link it with the work on spending?
So should we be trying to spend our money
on very different kinds of emotional
experiences to sort of buy different
kinds of variety for ourselves in our
emotional life?
I think so. I mean, I think if you look
at at some of the research, uh, on,
on how to spend your money to get happier.
So Liz and I and our colleagues have
done research on spending money on other
people as a way to make yourself happier.
And that's a thing that we don't often do.
So if you think about what we do
every day and how we feel every day,
just the act of spending money
on someone else is different.
And that difference in that
diversity might be enough.
Tom Gilovich and leaf and Bowen and
their colleagues have shown that spending
money on experiences instead of stuff
for yourself is also associated with more
happiness. And again, you can think that
buying different experiences, again,
we'll increase the diversity of your
emotions and that might be part of the
reason why buying
experiences makes you happy.
So it could be part of the reason that
spending your money differently makes you
happier is simply because doing
different things make you happier,
which I think is what our
research tends to suggest.
That's really interesting.
So we should be spending our money on
other people and spending it on different
kinds of experiences.
All right. And ideally both
at the same time actually.
So experiences with other people
is kind of a the perfect storm.
Excellent. Excellent. So I mean,
you've done such interesting research
on spending and happiness and emotional
diversity. So if you think about
the face of the future for emotion,
what do you see in store? What do you
see as the next steps on the horizon?
To me,
I think one of the most important next
steps and the reason that it unimportant
next step is because it's very hard to do,
is to look at how these interventions
that that I and lots of other people have
been coming up with to change your
happiness in the moment might lead to
sustained changes in
your overall happiness.
And we know from lots of research by
Dan Gilbert and other people that in
general we have this hedonic treadmill
where once something good happens,
but then we kind of get used to it and
we end up a little bit closer to where we
were when we started then we'd like to be.
But thinking about how the
kinds of interventions that um,
behavioral scientists are coming up with
can not only make you happier today or
this week, but really change
your happiness over time. And,
and both in regular people, you
know, just making you feel fine,
but we could make you a little happier.
But I think especially in clinical
populations where you have, you know,
severe depression,
are there interventions that scientists
have come up with that can change their
wellbeing? Again, not just
for a day or an hour a week,
but really in the longer term.
That's great.
And so when you think about the
future and a big part of the future,
our new students and people wanting to
embark and new directions and emotion,
if they came to you, Mike, and
they said, what advice were you,
what'd you have for us as we're thinking
about, you know, embarking on this new,
uh, you know, area of emotion, what
should I do? What might you say to them?
That's a hard one. I think one of
the key things for any academic,
I still work on new things. And so, uh,
which is terrible advice to someone
and she was working on something new,
but don't tell them what the new thing is.
But I think if you think about
the way emotion goes, you know,
there are different researchers working
on different aspects of emotion.
And often the biggest impact research
is people who take an entirely new
approach to how emotion works
in everyday life. You know,
whether it's looking at different
populations or coming up with new
interventions,
whatever those things might be,
there's a tendency to kind of iterate
and as you know and academia on,
now that we know this one thing,
let's really unpack it and that's very,
very important for science because we
need to understand what's going on in
great detail.
But for a new researcher,
which you're really trying to push for
is what is a new area of emotion that we
haven't studied and my sense is that
there are a million things that we don't
know about of all the great work that's
been done by people in the field.
There are a million things that we
don't know. So just as one example,
a graduate student of mine,
the lean to nick and I started a project
on the feeling of being talked about,
which is I think,
and if you think about how you would feel
if two people went into a room and you
knew they were talking about you and
you had to sit there and wait until they
came back. It's a weird
aversive, unique feeling.
I think it's probably a actually an
important human emotion because gossip and
reputation are so fundamental
to how humans work, and we know,
I'm not saying this is the
most important emotion,
but we know nothing about that feeling.
It probably drives a lot of
social behavior and other things.
I think there's lots of emotions and
people disagree on how to define what an
emotion is,
but there's lots of these really just
street emotional experiences that are very
fundamental to being human
that we know very little about,
and they're just waiting
to be studied by somebody.
That's interesting.
I guess we'll have to wonder what people
are going to say about our interview
today. You know, we're not
watching. Well, thanks.
It can be ugly. It can. It's a
discrete emotion experience. Hmm. Well,
thanks Mike for Speaking with us today.
This concludes our expert and emotion
interview with Dr. Michael Norton from
Harvard University.